[拍手]
えっ読者は大学から来ますと渡辺貴仁ですどうぞよろしくお願いします
絵図ですねじゃあ
まず最初にですね皆さん机の上に置かれている
なんかよくわからない法案とかとクッキーが生まれていると思います
まずそのを1の方の負担
とってみましょうか
どうですか何が入ってますか
はいそうです興梠が入っているんです
エゴで僕が食べれるように要職者コールですのでぜひ皆さん
あの食べてみてください
other ちゃんが付いてますよ故障が続いています
でまぁエビカニアレルギー激しい人はもしかしたらたら寝方がいいかもしれないんです
ね
まあどうしても食べるの無理だと言う人はですね
横のクッキーの方も食べてみてください
愛知網にそのクッキーの方にはですね1枚につきだいたい10匹から15匹分くらいの
鴻臚井
音の感想コールには練りこまれてグッキーです
どうですかちょっと僕の方からよく見えてないんですけれどえっと美味しいなぁって
たぶんみなさん僕は思っていると思います
で多分は徳島の薬でなんか妙なことをやってんが空けた方が思われているだろうと予想
していますけれど僕はいたって真面目です
で
これ近い将来の先取りということで
部分は皆様にお出ししているということです
これ近い将来は者ですね確実に食の一つの選択肢として厚労委が食卓になることを考え
ています
今日はそんな職業のコオロギについてのお話をさせていただきたいと思います
なので僕
毎日奪って航路に子ちゃん出てるような興梠もですね研究をずっとしています
毎日このコオロギを買っている部屋ですね
だいたい10万匹ぐらいに買ってますかね理由なところで日々研究を行なっております
最初にですねまず僕がなぜ食用コールで研究を始めたのか
っていうところをお話しさせていただきたいと思います
僕のお供とはですね食欲おりの研究していたわけではなくて
大学生のとき研究室に入ってから13年間
今もちろん続けているんですけれど
1個の受精卵からどうやって生きモノの形も例えば体とか足とかそういうものがどう
やって出来て来るのかっていう研究を心気を使って研究してません
その中でですね五彩池になっては何か
goldie を使ってですね研究するだけじゃなくて
世界の人類に対して貢献できるような研究って何かないのかなというふうに考えるよう
になってきました
それで何を思ったかというと
人類の新たな食用が淡白そしてゴールが使えるんじゃないのか
いうふうに思うようになったわけです
現状世界を見てみても
まあ食用後コオロギを研究している研究者もほとんどいませんし
日本を見ても全然いません
それねじゃあそういう職業のゴールが研究するんやったら
は長いこと京急し的な我々しかないだろう
っていうような思い出ですねこの研究をスタートさせました
他の産業じゃなくてですね
なんで食用にするのかっていうところなんですけれどこれは近い将来必ず来ると言われ
ている
食糧問題っていうのがあるから
2050年いやですね地球上の人口90億に超えて105人に迫ると言われていて
食糧不足が必ずくるという風に帝国をされています
その中で2013年に国連がですね
食糧問題がかなり大きな
そういう希望になるんですと昆虫食を推奨するという報告書を出しました
じゃあなぜコード中華いいのかいうところなんですけれども
まず1つは今の会者が千種
である牛2取りなんかと比較すると
コオロギ同じ寮の3コスチップを生産するのに餌の量がめちゃめちゃせなくて済むん
ですね
さらに同じようなことは水に関してもいえいえて牛だと今2000 l なっていう音
もない量水が必要になってくるわけですですけれど
興梠が頭楯の業務言っとるです
いうようなことがあります
またさらにですね
温室効果ガスかなり少ないということが言われています
畜産が出す音出稿がガスっていうのは実は
they 世界で車ガラス温室講座っているも多いと言われています
そういうところでかなり環境に右翼ないということが言われているんですけれどもそれ
はコオロギで興梠に置き換えた時にですねかなり温室効果ガスを減らすことができる
つまり今週は持続可能で環境にやさしいたんがですが
いうふうなことがあるということです
今昆虫の中でじゃなんでゴールになのかという話になるんですけれども起こる
僕が研究をつけたからというだけではないんですね
興梠には養殖軸3 s にするって言った場合にはかなり良い生物特性が詰まっている
ということです
まず1つは育つのが流行りシェイクが早いということです
これ実は結構大事ですねまぁコオロギだとを育てていればだいたい40日くらいで収穫
も収穫というのが正しいのか知りませんけれど
就学というステージまで育てることができます
例えばあの今週で言えばですねセミーとかは食べるとナッツの味がしておいしい
なってよく言われるんですけども育つのに最低813件かかるんですね
長いものだと21年とかそんなゼミもいるわけです
そんなものですね養殖するなるとあっをなんとか人の手間だとか
その間の天才がとかもあるのでコストが尋常じゃないようになると
村年頃位だと効率よく砂を得られるということです
さらにですね達何でも食べるという雑食性であるというのがつ良いところです
皆様にご存知じゃないかもしれませんけれど今週というのは実は一つの昆虫は一つの
ものを食べるって言うような遊びは食べ物始まって1本ジュっていうのはすごく多いん
ですね例えば回避あ長はキャベツとか油な
例えば275また寄ったんですけどまたは基本的にはそこらへんに生えている生の房
しか食べないというのがあります
蒼天航路ではですね本当にその辺の
分かりがと雑草みたいなもんだから
お持ちの方も食べた日迷宮みたいな牛なんかも食べるとステージも食べ
ということがあって何でも食べるというのはすごく大事ですつまりこれどういうことか
と言いますと
逃げが食べなかっ
ものつまり食糧の山さんだとか
あとは人間がまあ少々食べづらいような v なんかでも考慮育てることができると
いうことです
そして先ほど皆さんあ食べていただいたのではあると思う美味しいということがあり
ます
根治他のものを見てみればたが2階虫とか不具合も失敗あったが色々あるんですけど氷
がその辺
撮影ようなしてついてもなくて食べやすい美味しいということがいます
他にも例えば高齢を食べていれば健康に良いとか言うこともはたくさんあるんですけど
もここで終わります少し割愛させていただきます
じゃあ将来食べるのはかっ
今までは誰が食べているんだということが皆さん家になると思うんですけれども
サステイなく持続可能で環境に優しくてしかも体によいヘルシーな食べ物ってじゃあ誰
が食べるかというと今は開眼ぐセレブが食べるんですね
はこちらに示しているんですねアメリカだとかだと
ニコールキッドマンさんは虫がフルコース私はいつも食べてるんだっていう動画が実は
アップされています
ブーブーているということなんですねまぁアメリカの歌手 ki んですけど
ひぁっ here 結構
匂いということでいま海外のセレブのなかでは特にアメリカのセレブはそういうものを
香炉木のスナックなんかを子供にあげるということが増えてきているようです
実際市場としてはですねパンダとかあとはプロティンがーミディア
そういうものも実際粒あたり売られています
そういう意味でいえば日本は本当にご昼食が後進国
言えるかもしれません
いやいやちゃうじゃん後進国で先進国アメリカだけじゃねえ持っ桜花もしれないんです
けど実際
アメリカの他にもう今ブームになっている国っていうのがいくつかあります
その一つがですね北欧の国々欧州の中で北欧の国々なんですね
北欧の国々は結構そういう持続可能っていうところに安定の高い人たちが多くて
その後国連の2013年の報告書が出た時にもう
早くからフィンランド国の政府自体が今住職推進しますというふうに表明しています
まだ2018年の1月なんですけれど
ヨーロッパ eu 全体で
昆虫を自由に取引してもいいですよというノーベルフードとして認めますと言う
そういうふうな報告が出てですね自由な取引を解禁されたんですねそれによってかなり
大きな広がりを見せているということです
ヘルシンキのスーパーなんかでファンが普通に香炉霧のファンが売られていてしかも
それから振り切れるというような現象がいま起きているようです
さて者市場が今ができて言っているというのはわかりいただけたと思うんですけれど
その市場ができてきているということはつまりコオロギを養殖している人がどこかに
いるということです
どの国を見てもですね
これが結構今のかかる古典的な方法で飼われていたわけですよ
これ先ほど私が買っている様子なんですけれどこれも古典的な方法で今わかっています
衣装ケースお部屋がにザフト並べてその衣装ケースの中を見ると
卵ケースまで隠れ家ですねを入れて餌を受けて水を入れてということをします
当然餌とか水はなくなるのでそれをいちいち50したりという作業
かなり手間がかかる
ですね
こういうことをやっていたんでは大きな食糧問題の解決そういう産業的に
産業的な持続性というのがあまりないんじゃないかという風に考えていまして
9 c 9方法を新たに自動化していったり
洗練させていく必要があると考えています
そこで今私は興梠の新たな飼育のシステムというの構築しているところです
開発していますコンセプトとしてはこちらに示しているように空間を最大限利用できる
ように積層型の多段積層型にしてエイズと餌はほぼ
同年供給できるをそうすれば人の手間がかからなくなるということです
碓田はゴミとかは下に落として後はま病気とかが出ないように通気性を良くしていこう
という語彙コンセプトで今開発を進めています
特許の関係でですねは詳しいところがお見せできないんですけれども
こちらは写真にあるように
今それぞれユニットの一つの部分を開発しているところですよ
近い将来おそらく実用化へ来そうな
できそうだなというところまでは何とかこぎ着けているようなところです
さて今宿3っていうとですねほとんど不思
2 treat you が原因です動きの牛の焼肉を食べました
美味しい c はすごく僕も大好きなんですけれども
問題にはもういくつかあるんですね
愚痴とか普段取り全部人と近い義務ですんで
そこの人畜共通の病気とかも出たりします狂牛病だとか
豚インフル鳥インフそういうのが出れば大量に早速しないといけない
また
チークのメンっていうところから考えると人材不足合計尺側
資料を餌を輸入しているということによる
そこの自給率の低下がいろいろ問題があります
そういうところの問題はですねコオロギでは
解決していこうと今奮闘しているところです
まず日本でこの問題を解決でそれを世界の食糧問題に役立てていきたいと考えており
ます
エコールに1文字で漢字で書くとですね
このような感じを書きます
共にいる牛と書いてゴール
表と呼びます
つまりこれ長い連結内でですねもずっと人と一緒にコオロギはいたということです
私はですねこの香炉にをこの先も
com に生きていくような虫にしたいと考えており
香炉木を養殖する
つまり用鏡をですね
うしうだ鳥同じような土俵に乗せるまあ新たな畜産としての窯業を確立させていきたい
と考えています
これからも研究頑張っていきますので皆さん動画
商品あげれば買ってください
ご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]